i've spoken to people
who have been much more involved with
the 360 series than i have i'm i'm a
complete charlatan i've written a few
fortran programs that ran on top of
system 360. but people who i've been in
contact with now say
we admired it a lot for its achievements
but it was not
not a user-friendly or programmer
friendly environment i've not found
anybody who is prepared to stand up and
say yeah it was the bee's news it was
wonderful they all said yeah it was
a bit of a mishmash some really good
things in it some things that were awful
to cope with
didn't they think about writing it in a
higher level language
wouldn't that have got better
productivity because of course this is
all in assembler
so what would the story be then about
trying to use
a higher level language
and
at this era i mean i do have a little
bit of
hands-on knowledge not so much on the
360 series but on the ico 1906
where the rcl provided software didn't
let me do this but
algol 68 compiler written for
the
rcl1906a did enable me to do it is to
yeah just
be able to use the higher level language
for things like if statements or case
statements things involving layouts and
and also of course to have the higher
level language be capable of working out
for square arrays or rectangular arrays
which scientists and engineers love but
as we all know
they're not held in a square format
directly or a rectangular form you have
to work out in a linear apparently
linear level of
memory where exactly is
byte number a555 that's holding this
character i'm interested in and you have
to do multiplication sums you have to
know how many bytes there are in each of
these objects in your array you have to
know whether the underlying architecture
is storing the array by
rows or storing it by columns now
interestingly at bell labs before dennis
and ken invented c can you guess what
ken thompson's chosen the high level
language was i will say at the outset
that his first stab at anything was to
write an interpreter for it in the b
language very cut down bcbl
i i'm guessing just because of what
you've just said fortran yes
the number of times that ken in those
very early days says oh yes and once
we've done that we must do a fortran
compiler
fortran can be amazingly spartan and
minimalist in its approach but if you're
struggling to find a language that will
just about do
as a system programming language and
nothing else is available i know from
experience i've done
mixed fortran assembler programming
so long as the people writing the link
editor get the assembler modules talking
to the fortran modules okay it can be
remarkably
effect effective what does a compiler do
with the assembler when you've got a
mixed language the comp as far as the
compiler knows
you write a
procedure call a subroutine call out for
a subroutine called fred with parameters
a b and c
little does
the fortran compiler know
that the thing that will merge this into
a uniform thing is that fred is written
in assembler
and the rules on the assembler manual
say
we can help you if you will only pass
your
actual parameters in registers five six
and seven shall we say you follow that
then we the link editor for assembler
level modules
and that's the thing in the end the
fortran compiles down to being assembler
level modules this all got linked in a
uniform and harmonious way because there
are agreed conventions for how you pass
information between the two
the thing that really gets you in
vanilla early fortran was it helped
enormously with the logic the if and the
case statements you could do them as it
were
although fortran didn't have case at the
time but doing array calculations and
getting that right what it couldn't do
then
in most fortrans was actual detailed bit
twiddling you know masking with bit
patterns that typically had to be saved
for assembler and addressed at the end
of a known interface as to how you
passed your eight bits across to be
twiddled with or whatever
so we've now mentioned the fact that if
you wanted a slightly higher level
approach then fortran could come to your
rescue if you wanted something better
than that wouldn't these more modern
languages
um
pl1 if you're an ibm disciple algol 68
if you were a weirdo committee person
that just loved high-level language
wouldn't they be even more helpful
and the answer to that is it depended on
the implementation
if i had to pull out one more anecdote
of
high-level language constructs that
eventually
became
house trained and became visible in
dennis and ken's early sea
it was structures now in arrays you
don't really name well you give the
array an overall name but the rest of
your calculations as to where the
elements are is all done by multiplying
because they're all rectangular or
square you can work it out but what you
really need
is something agglomerations where
they're not all the same size objects
structures in other words you need to be
able
to
name the fields or components in your
structure
and have them be
at different boundaries depending on
whether it's a set of reels or a set of
characters or a set of integers you need
to be able to name things and i'm told
by psychologists that this is a very
deep psychological need in the human
brain you've got to be able to give
things names and significantly kenneth
was more or less saying it was fourth
time lucky by the time we got structures
properly working you knew
that if you did
underscore
fred
it knew how many bytes displacement the
beginning of fred was from the start of
the beginning of the whole structure and
you didn't have to think oh
is it 10 bites ahead
the tables you were building up as you
compiled it told you that by counting
and dead reckoning the field called jim
had to be exactly 12 bytes downstream of
the start so if you say thing underscore
jim you've got it right but if you
actually moved on by what you thought
was the right number of bytes you'd get
off by one problems no it wasn't 10
bytes down it was 11 bytes down but if
you name if you
extend a labeling system to be the
principle of naming things you start
getting things right and he said that
was the key in early c
if you give them names and you label
them and let the compiler
make its own memo of how far
down these fields are within each of
these structures as you declare and
instantiate them
it will get it right for you so it's
getting higher level effect well yes
it's just so simple but what ken is
covertly saying is even genius
programmers like me make mistakes and
the way to stop making mistakes is to
have a labeling scheme and just trust it
so it's another part of something we
might want to get on to in another video
is
to what degree is it advantageous in
programming to hide things
and in a way giving these names is
hiding the ultimate hardware truth from
you
procedure interfaces is another way of
forcibly hiding things you know i'm not
going to have you replicate and squirt
out all my raw assembler i'm going to
get you to jump into one of my
procedures and i will tell you
which registers in the cpu to use for
passing over extra information
and you will trust that procedure and as
we get even further on into
agglomerations of procedures and arrays
and structs that develop into an even
bigger class thing in object-oriented
languages even more so does it apply
that being able to name things and from
the concatenation of the names being
able to work out where the heck that
object is in real memory is absolutely
vital
so we'd have to go over here across the
distributed shared memory link
to get the value and then we could bring
the value back so rather than taking 100
nanoseconds it would take in the order
of three hundred and half for most
people if they've never created a branch
before that just shows you the main
branch that you're currently on and it
will have a star next to except the one
it's showing you